PROFESSOR: So what I want to
do in today's lecture is to
shift gears somewhat from what
we've been talking about in
the first unit of the course.
As you know, the first unit of
the course was focused on a
set of texts that we're
concerned with what is
involved in human flourishing.
And though our opening text,
Glaucon's challenge from
Plato's Republic concerned
itself with morality and the
way in which morality
contributes to human
flourishing, we haven't, up
until this point, given much
attention to what philosophers
have had to say about the
nature of morality.
And so goal in this unit is, in
an incredibly accelerated
fashion, to introduce you today
and next Tuesday to two
of the most prominent moral
theories in the Western
tradition and then it then the
remaining sessions before
March break to talk to you about
some of the empirical
research about these
questions.
And I know we have
a wide range of
backgrounds in this class.
Some of you are now taking your
first philosophy course.
Some of you have taken an
entire course on ethics.
And so I've tried to pitch the
lecture in such a way that it
brings everybody up to speed,
but that it does so in a way
that I hope won't bore those
of you who have encountered
this before.
In particular, to make up for
the fact that there's very
little empirical psychology
in this lecture I have six
polling slides.
So those will come in in the
middle of the lecture right
when all of you are zoning out
because you got two hours of
sleep last night.
So even if you don't pay
attention for the first part,
you'll get to vote
in the middle.
All right, so what
is it that moral
philosophy sets out to do?
What is it to provide a
philosophical account of morality?
What moral philosophy is the
systematic endeavor to
understand moral concepts and
to justify moral principles
and theories.
That is: moral philosophy, even
if it ends up giving a
non-systematic answer to how it
is that morality works and
what it is that morality does,
does so within the endeavor of
thinking systematically about
the nature of morality.
What do I mean by morality?
I mean that moral theories aim
to provide accounts of terms
like "right" and "wrong,"
"permissible" and
"impermissible," "ought" and
"ought not," "forbidden,"
"good," "bad," and the like--and
to provide an
account of the behaviors to
which those terms apply.
It is fundamentally, to remind
you of a terminological
distinction that we've made
before, a normative as opposed
to a descriptive enterprise.
Philosophical moral theory
doesn't aim to tell us how
people act.
It aims to tell us how people
ought to act if they wish to
conform to the constraints that
morality places on them.
In particular, moral philosophy
is concerned with
providing a principled answer
to three kind of questions.
The first kind of question we
encountered already in the
context of Glaucon's
Challenge.
It's the question of
moral motivation.
"Why should we want to act in
keeping which what morality
demands of us?
And a minute I'll give you a
sense of the range of answers
that have been provided
to that question.
So the first question that moral
philosophy asks is why
would we even want
to be moral.
It then asks the particular
question, "what should we do
insofar as we seek
to act morally?".
And about that we've had very
little to say so far.
We know that according to
Aristotle, to be brave, one
acts as the brave one does.
But Aristotle just put forth
bravery as a virtue without
any explanation of what it was
that made bravery fall into
the category of virtues and
cowardice fall into that
category of vices other
than the very general
analysis of the mean.
And we haven't looked at any
specific claims about
particular actions being morally
acceptable or not.
So the second sort of thing that
a moral theory tries to
do-- and, again, I'll give some
examples in a minute--
is give us specific answers to
the question "is this act
morally OK?".
In addition, what a moral theory
aims to do is to tell
us why we gave the answers that
we did in question two.
"In virtue of what common
feature are the acts that fall
into the category of moral to be
distinguished from the acts
that fall into the category of
immoral?" So what do answers
to these three questions
look like?
Let's start since we've
encountered it already with
the question of moral
motivation.
So one category of answers that
one might give to why it
is that we would be moral,
act in keeping with the
constraints of morality, is
a self-interest account.
So one might give an account
which says when you behave
morally, things run smoothly.
As Socrates argues in response
to Glaucon, when you behave in
keeping with the constraints of
morality, there is harmony
in your soul.
And that provides you with the
possibility of a certain kind
of flourishing.
Or you might have what's
implicit in the very first
argument that Glaucon gives, a
view that morality provides a
certain kind of stability
in society.
Each of us behaving in
pro-social ways increases the
likelihood of others around us
behaving in pro-social ways.
And so we reach a kind of
equilibrium state whereby
things run smoothly if
everybody behaves
pro-socially.
And we'll talk about that again
at the beginning of the
political philosophy section.
So one kind of self-interest
theory is a theory that
appeals to a certain kind of
coordination, either a
coordination among the parts of
the soul, or coordination
across individuals
in a society.
A second kind of self-interest
theory is what we might call a
get good stuff theory.
So this lies at the heart on
some religious traditions.
Here's what you get if you
act in keeping with the
constraints of morality: you get
eternal life in a really
nice place.
Here's what you get if you don't
act in keeping with the
constraints of morality: you get
eternal continuation in a
really unpleasant place.
So the notion that there is some
reward beyond earth for
behaving in moral ways is an
example of a self-interested
justification of morality.
Or one might give the sort of
justification that Adeimantus
gives in response to Glaucon's
challenge.
Adeimantus point out that one
of the things morality
provides you with is enhanced
reputation.
So as a result of behaving in
keeping with the standards of
morality, you come to be
perceived as having behaved in
that way, and that reputation
brings to you some value.
Or it might be, as Aristotle
discusses at the end of Book
10, that society is structured
in some way that motivates
people to act in keeping with
the constraints of morality
because doing so is a way
of avoiding punishment.
Many of us obey speeding laws
for precisely that reason.
We obey them most especially
when there are flashing lights
in our vicinity.
But we can have an internalized
version of the
reduction of punishment
as well.
Part of the Freudian picture
that we heard about in the
Divided Soul lecture discussed
the development of conscience
as an internalization of
external rules, whereby the
super ego gets upset when the id
behaves in ways that aren't
in keeping with the constraints
of morality.
And one can have a non-Freudian
version of that
as well that appeals to the
notion of conscience.
So the idea that what morality
brings you is either the
possibility of salvation or
enhanced reputation or the
possibility of not being
punished by external laws or
the possibility of not being
punished by one's conscience
is another version a
self-interest theory.
So that's one kind of
justification one might
provide for behaving
in moral ways.
A second very different kind
of justification says the
reason we act morally is because
normative features are
fundamental features
of the world.
There's a brute "ought"
out there.
It's a fact about reality that
what we are morally obliged to
do is to act in whatever ways
it is that morality demands
and not out of self-interest,
but simply because we are
responsive to that feature of
the world, we are motivated to
act morally.
A third kind of justification,
third kind of explanation of
more motivation, is what we
might call a factive theory
that says roughly this is
just the way people are.
So evolutionary accounts that
say pro-social behaviors have
been selected for, perhaps
because they enable the
resolution of coordination
problems. But whatever the
explanation, pro-social behavior
says this theory had
been selected for.
So it's a brute fact about the
world that we behave in
pro-social ways--not a brute
normative fact about the
world, just a brute descriptive
fact about the
world that we behave
in that way.
Or you might have, not an
evolutionary based version of
this, but a version that says
look, this is just the way the
human soul expresses itself
when it conforms to its
natural state.
So you might have a theory of
morality that says the reason
to behave morally is out of
self-interest. You might have
a theory of morality that says
the reason to behave morally
is because of altruism.
You might have a theory of
morality that says the reason
to behave morally is just that's
the way we do behave.
Or you might have some sort
of combination theory.
And we've talked already about
the first of these, the
self-interest theory.
And as this section of the
course goes on, we'll talk
more about some of the other
sorts of explanation.
So those are some examples of
the kinds of answers that are
given to the first question,
the question of moral
motivation.
What kinds of issues arise
when we think about the
question of moral behavior?
Well you saw a number of
examples of this in the
reading that we did for today.
One kind question that moral
theories set out to provide
answers to is the question of
whether it's either morally
required or morally permitted to
harm one person in order to
help many others.
So Bernard Williams' story of
Jim and the Indians, where Jim
is presented with a case where
if he's willing to shoot one
of 20 prisoners, the other 19
will be set free, whereas if
he's unwilling to shoot
that one, all 20 of
them will be shot.
Or the Omelas story, where
we're told the story of a
society whose flourishing
depends upon the suffering of
a single child.
Or the trolley cases that I
presented you with in the very
first lecture, where a trolley
is headed down a track towards
five people, and we're in a
position to deflect the
trolley in some way so
that one ends up
being killed instead.
Those are examples of schematic
representations of
the kinds of questions
that moral theories
confront all the time.
Whenever we think about
deferrals of threat --
is it right to quarantine a
population suffering from a
particular illness in a way that
will cause harm to them
but benefit the rest
of society? --
we are thinking about these
sorts of questions.
So one sort of question that
moral philosophy aims to
answer is the question of
whether this sort of trade off
is morally required or
morally permitted.
A particularly profound version
of that question comes
out when we think about what our
moral duties are to those
who are less fortunate.
So the philosopher Peter Singer
has famously argued
that the entire structure of the
first world and the third
world is a morally illegitimate
one because it
involves an unwillingness on the
part of those in the first
world to do what is morally
demanded of them, namely to
take a large proportion
of their resources and
redistribute those to people
who are suffering from
extraordinarily easily
curable illnesses.
People who don't have mosquito
nets, people who don't have
vaccinations, people who don't
have clean water, people who
don't have access to basic
medical care in the first five
years that would, for example,
prevent lifelong blindness.
So another question that moral
theory asks--in some ways of
version of the earlier
question--is in general what
our duties are to those who
are less fortunate.
It also asks questions like
this: Are these sorts of
behaviors morally mandatory?
Is it morally mandatory for us
to behave in ways that help
the environment, say
by recycling?
Is it morally mandatory for us
to act in certain ways towards
non-human animals, perhaps
by being vegetarian?
Is it morally required
of us to worship a
deity in some way?
Is religious worship something
that's morally mandatory?
Is something like respect for
elders, a fundamental part of
traditional moral frameworks,
morally mandatory?
And moral theories also ask
questions like: Are these
kinds of things morally
permissible.
Is abortion morally
permissible?
Is euthanasia morally
Is capital punishment
morally permissible?
How about sex before marriage?
How about lying for one
or another motivation?
How about, as Kant's going to
argue in our next reading,
failing to cultivate one's
talents, which Kant thinks is
a violation of moral mandate?
So these are the kinds of
questions that moral theories
aim to provide answers to.
And it might seem like a
heterogeneous bunch.
But it gives you a sense of the
generality of explanation
that moral theories
seek to provide.
So let's turn to four major
moral theories in the western
tradition and think about how
it is that they could simply
categorically provide
answers to this
wide range of questions.
So the kind of moral theory that
we're going to discuss in
today's lecture primarily is
a moral theory known as
utilitarianism.
It tells us an act is moral
insofar as it produces the
greatest good for the
greatest number.
It takes as its fundamental
notion the notion of good.
And it gives us answers to
the questions that we've
previously asked ourselves as
long as we know how goods are
distributed in response
to them.
So if we know what it is that
produces happiness in sentient
beings, then utilitarianism will
give us an answer to the
question of whether being
vegetarian is morally mandated.
It'll tell us to take the amount
of happiness that's
distributed across sentient
beings, and look at which
distribution is going
to maximize
the amount of happiness.
So utilitarianism gives us one
sort of systematic answer to
this question.
A second sort of answer to this
question, which we'll
discuss in lecture on Tuesday,
is the answer given by Kant
and the deontological
tradition.
What Kant says is that an act
is moral insofar as it's
performed as the result of
acting with the correct sort
of motivation.
It takes as its primary notion
not the notion of goodness,
but rather the notion
of rightness.
And on that basis, Kant is
going to give a bunch of
answers to our specific
questions.
In particular, he's going to
argue that it's not OK to
sacrifice the good of the one
for the good of the many.
And he's going to argue that
lying is morally unacceptable.
And we'll talk next class about
how from a very abstract
principle like this one one
can derive these sorts of
particular answers.
We've already looked at the
ancient traditional answer to
this in Aristotle, that an act
is moral insofar as it's
performed as the results of
having a virtuous character.
And so what Aristotle says to
us is look and see how the
well-raised one would behave.
And once you see what is that
the virtuous one does, you can
learn through his or her
example what it is that morality
demands of us.
And a final tradition about
which we won't have much to
say in this lecture is, of
course, a basis for morality
which has stood at the center
of western culture for at
least 2,000 years, which is the
idea that an act is moral
insofar as it conforms to what
the divinity demands of us.
So one can provide an
explanation, as the
utilitarian does, that
makes appeal to
the notion of goodness.
One can provide a justification
that makes
appeal, as deontology does, to
the notion of rightness.
One can provide a justification
that makes
appeal, as virtue ethics does,
to the notion of virtuousness.
Or one can provide an account
that makes appeal, as
religious ethics does, to the
notion of divine mandate.
So let's think a little more
about the relation among these
three particular theories, the
ones on which we're going to
focus in the context of this
class, as a way of coming to
understand the particular theory
that we're thinking
about today, namely
utilitarianism.
So virtue ethics focuses its
attention on the actor, not
the person who stands up on the
stage and recites lines
from Hamlet, but rather the
actor who performs an act that
will be moral or not.
Deontology focuses its
attention on the act.
It looks not at who's doing it,
but rather at what act is
done and under what
description.
consequentialism, by contrast,
looks not at who does the act
and looks not at the description
under which the
act is done, but looks rather
at the consequences that the
act brings about.
And we've encountered virtue
theory in the voice--
see if you recognize
this gentleman--
in the voice of Aristotle.
We will encounter deontology in
the voice of Immanuel Kant.
And what we're going
to discuss today is
consequentialism and, in
particular, utilitarianism in
the voice of John Stuart Mill.
So let's look now at what it is
that Mill has to say about
the fundamental nature
of morality.
So what Mill contends--
and let me say we're coming up
on the clicker slide, so if
you're zoning out, it's time
to pull out your clicker.
And in about four or
five minutes, we'll
be doing some polls.
So Mill contends that the right
kind of framework for
thinking about moral theories
is a consequentialist
framework, so not one that looks
at the actor as virtue
theory does, not one that looks
at the act as deontology
does, but rather one that looks
at the consequences in
the way that consequentialism
does.
The degree of moral rightness of
an act is determined by its
consequences.
And Mill provides a particular
version of this.
He says the degree of moral
rightness of an act is
determined by a particular kind
of consequence, namely
the utility that the
act produces.
So you might have a
consequentialist theory that
says the degree of moral
rightness of an act is
determined by its consequences,
namely, for
example, the amount of bananas
that it produces.
It would be an odd moral theory,
but it would be a
consequentialist theory that
says the degree of moral
rightness of an act is
determined by its
consequences, in particular
by its degree of banana
production.
So that would be a very
general kind of
consequentialist theory.
Utilitarian theories are
a particular kind of
consequentialist theory that
says the degree of moral
rightness of an act is
determined by its
consequences, in particular
by the amount of
utility--usefulness, happiness
in Mill's account of what kind
of utility we're concerned
with--by the amount of utility
that it produces.
That means, to remind you of the
handouts that you got in
section this week, that to be
utilitarian is a sufficient
condition to be
consequentialist, but not a
necessary one.
And to be a consequentialist
is a necessary condition on
being a utilitarian, but
not a sufficient one.
And if what I just said isn't
completely obvious to you,
take a look at the second side
of the handout that you got in
section this week.
So Mill not only makes a
utilitarian commitment, he
actually in the course of making
that commitment makes
two very particular claims that
I now want ask you to
think about in light of
some particular cases.
The first is the famous
formulation of the greatest
happiness principle, which in
your text appears right at the
beginning on page 77
in the reprint.
Mills says famously, "Actions
are right in proportion as
they tend to promote happiness,
wrong as they tend
to promote the reverse of
happiness." And he continues a
few pages later to clarify that
what he means is not the
agent's own happiness, but
that of all concerned.
In a minute we'll think through
what that implies.
The second commitment of Mill's
that I want you to
think about is one runs straight
on in opposition to
what we talked about in
Aristotle last week.
Mill says the motive has
nothing to do with the
morality of the action.
"He who saves another creature
from drowning does what is
morally right whether his motive
be duty or the hope of
being paid for his trouble." The
motivation with which an
act is performed, says Mill,
tells us nothing about the
morality of the act.
He doesn't deny that it tells us
something about the actor.
He's perfectly happy to say that
somebody who does the act
out of the hope of being paid is
in some way different from
the person who does act out of
a sense of duty or moral
obligation.
But as far as the moral value
of the act itself is
concerned, Mill thinks there
is no difference.
So that's the first question
that I wanted to ask you.
Take the case that
Mill's described.
You see somebody drowning
in a lake.
And the question is this, is
your act of saving that person
morally right, morally virtuous,
moral only if it's
done out of duty?
I want to save that person
because it's the right thing
to do or some other sort
of pro-social motive.
If you think that, push one.
Or is the act morally right
regardless of its motive even
if you do it because there's a
big sign up on the trees that
say save a drowning person:
$10,000 reward.
And so you think: "$10,000,
that's good money." And in you
jump into the water.
All right, I'll push the
ten second timer.
We have roughly 50 of
you, 70 of you.
Good, numbers are jumping up.
Let's just see whether
instinctively this room is
filled with Kantians or filled
with consequentialists.
So, interestingly, there's a
pretty close to even split.
Most of you seem to side with
Mill on the question that an
act is morally right regardless
of the motive.
But a sizable portion of you are
going to be pleased when
we read Kant, who gives the
answer that you offer.
And one of the things that we
want to do in section next
week is to have those of you who
fall on one or the other
side of this question talk
through with others around you
why it is that you either fell
into this group or you felt
into this one.
So, so far Mill's doing
pretty well.
He has a slight majority
of you on his side.
I now want to present you with
a series of cases to ask what
you think about the greatest
happiness principle.
Remember, Mill says that an
act is moral insofar as it
produces the greatest happiness
for the greatest
number, where we're not
concerned with how that
happiness is distributed
across individuals.
So let's start with
a following case.
There's an act which you can
perform which will give you
100 units of happiness.
Each of those colorful
smiley faces--
aren't you all feeling
pro-social in their light?
Each of those smiley faces
represents 10 units of happiness.
So suppose you have a fan.
It's a very hot day,
and you have a fan
that blows upon you.
And the coolness of that fan
just provides you with 100
units of happiness.
Or suppose you have some
delicious cookies, and eating
those cookies provides you with
100 units of happiness.
In addition, performing that act
provides 100 other people
with one unit of
happiness each.
Suppose your fan blows a little
bit outside of your
room so that in addition to
cooling you off 100 units, it
cools the people in the next
room off one unit apiece.
Or supposed that when you
finish eating your 100
cookies, there are 100 cookies
left over, and each of 100
people get to have one
cookie, and it brings
them one unit of happiness.
OK.
So that's act one.
It has a total of two hundred
units of happiness.
You get 100 units, and each of
100 other people get one unit.
So your choice is between
performing that act and
performing an act which I'm
going to call act two, which
has exactly the same effect
for you, right?
It brings you 100 units
of happiness.
So here you are with your
100 units of happiness.
But in this case, if you made
a slight change in the angle
of your fan, for example, you
would be just as cool as you
were in the first case.
But it would double the amount
of happiness of the people on
the outside, right?
You angle this fan slightly
differently.
And instead of being cooled
one unit, the people are
cooled two units.
Or instead of throwing out
your trash at the end of
eating your cookies so that
people only get one unit of
happiness, you leave the other
cookies around so that
everybody else gets two
units of happiness.
In this case, by performing an
act which has no different
consequences for you as far as
happiness is concerned, you
double the happiness of a
hundred other people with
respect to the act.
So the question is
simply this.
Given the choice between act
one, which brings a total of
200 units of happiness, 100
units for you and one unit for
each of 100 other people, or act
two, which brings the same
amount of happiness to you, but
200 units of happiness to
others and hence a total of
three hundred, do you think--
push one if you think only
act one is moral.
That is only the one where you
get 100 units, and everybody
else gets one.
Push two if you think only act
two is moral, the one where
you redirect your fan slightly
or whatever it is that you do
to double the happiness of those
around you, or three,
that either one of those
is a moral act.
OK.
And I'm going the turn our timer
on so that we have 10
seconds to see how it is that
your first take on Mill's
greatest happiness
principle goes.
And let's see how the
numbers come out.
OK.
So very few of you think that
the moral act as the one
whereby you get 100 units of
happiness, and the 100 others
get one unit.
But you're roughly equally
divided on the question of
whether morality mandates that
you redistribute your
resources in such a way that
they go also to others.
So most of our discussion in the
remaining slides will be
concerned with when this
44 percent moves
over to another place.
But I'll be interested to see
how all of this plays out.
OK.
So that was our first case, the
case where at no cost to
yourself you can bring
happiness to others.
Let's now contrast exactly
the same first case.
You get 100 units of happiness;
100 others
get one unit each.
So there's a total of 200 units,
with the second case,
we'll call this act three, where
in order to redirect the
goods, you bring your own
happiness down to 50 units.
So in order to redirect your
fan in such a way that the
other people get two units
each, you have a slight
reduction in the amount
of utility for you.
But it's still the
case that this is
more beneficial overall.
So act one you get 100
unit of happiness,
other people get one.
Act two, you've reduced your
happiness, you've redirected
the fan, you're eating fewer
of the cookies, but you've
distributed it in such
a way that others
get their two units.
OK.
So the question is only act one,
where you get 100 units,
and everybody else gets one,
only act two, where you get 50
units, and everybody else gets
two, but the total is higher,
or either one?
And, again, we'll open polling
with the ten second timer.
And let's see how
the numbers go.
All right.
So little bit of change over
to either act being moral.
More of you think that it is
morally required to increase
the happiness of those around
you when there's no harm to
yourself than if you think is
required when there is some
cost to yourself.
Notice that Mill is very clear
that what is morally required
is number two here, that only
the act which brings the
greater amount of utility to
the community as a whole is
morally required.
Turn to a third case.
The first version is
the same as before.
You get 100 units.
Everybody else gets one.
Now, in order to do the good
for others you have to
experience some kind
of disutility.
You turn your fan totally
away from yourself.
But the result of that
is that 100 others
get three units each.
So now the question is this.
Is the act that is morally
permitted of you, or is the
act, that is a moral act, the
one that we've initially
presented, the one where you
have some disutility, but
other people get utility?
Or are these of equal value?
Notice the total of 200
units, 250 units.
So the first case, our classic
case, the second case one
where you experience
some discomfort.
But in exchange for that
discomfort, other people, not
you, experience some good.
OK.
Let's turn on the 10 second
timer and see
how this comes out.
OK.
So in this case, it appears
that very few of you are
siding with Mill.
A certain number of you are
here, saying that what we need
to do is to provide the
greatest good for
the greatest number.
And a sizable percentage of you
is growing to think that
perhaps morality doesn't demand
any sacrifices of you.
Let's go on.
Next case exactly like the last
one, except it's somebody
else who has 50 units of
disutility in order to
distribute three units
of utility to others.
So here's the case.
Either you get 100 units of
happiness, and others get one
unit each for a total
of 200 units.
Or let's assume you preserve
your 100 units
of happiness here.
We're leaving you out
of the equation.
And the question is this.
Suppose you are distributing
resources for
society as a whole.
There's a case where actually,
this act one ought to also be
someone else, so the case where
someone else gets 100
units of happiness, and 100
others get one unit each, or a
case where somebody else loses
50 units of happiness, but 100
others get three units each.
OK, so let's replace this you
in act one with someone else
and as the question of whether
a distribution of resources
across society, which produces
200 units of good in this form
or a distribution of resources
across society, which produces
250 units of good in this form,
a minor 50 units of
suffering by one for
three hundred units
of benefits by another.
Which one of those do you take
to be what morality demands?
And five, four, three,
two, one.
And let's see if there's any
change from the previous case.
OK.
All of a sudden, here
we get a radical
shifting of the graphs.
Almost 50 percent of you are
clear that the act that
requires bringing suffering to
one person, a reduction of
utility is not morally
mandated.
Later in the section that we are
encountering in the class
right now, we will consider
the question of whether
there's actually a fixed matter
of where the baseline
is and whether in fact this
radical shift that we get when
we moved from increasing utility
to decreasing utility
in people's psychology about
what morality demands is in
fact picking up on an artificial
difference.
Let's move to our final case.
So our final case is one where
either someone gets 100 units
of happiness, and 100 others
get one unit each.
So there's 200 units of
happiness, or a case--
hmm--
where someone gets 5,000 units
of happiness taken away, but
100 other people get five
hundred units each so that
there are 45,000 units of
happiness produced by the
performance of act six.
So the case here is either
a place where nobody has
anything bad going on, but the
total units of happiness are
only 200, or one person has a
lot of suffering going on, but
the total units of happiness
are 45,000.
OK.
And let's put the poll on with
our 10, nine, eight, seven,
six seconds and see
how it is that you
come out on this question.
All right.
On this question, which I know
already for many of your
reading responses to the Omelas
case, on which this is
model, it seems clear to a lot
of you that suffering of one
is not something that morality
demands of us even if the
result is an increase
in general utility.
Now, as you know, the Omelas
story tells the story of a
society where there is a
community of people, each of
whom has thousands and thousands
of units of utility.
They're incredibly happy
in how they live.
But that society exists as it
does only because there is a
child locked away whose
suffering permits the
society's joy.
And as you know in the story,
when children reach adulthood,
they are brought to see
the suffering child.
And most of them return to the
community of which they were a
part aware of this, shaped
by this, but
willing to tolerate it.
A smaller number of them, upon
seeing this, leave the society
altogether.
Now, the question that I want
you to think about in light of
your answer a few minutes ago
about what is demanded by
morality is some things that
seem to have the structure of
the Omelas story.
I take it that at some point
in the last 18 years or so,
someone has let you in on the
secret that the pleasure that
comes from eating meat depends,
as does the joy of
Omelas, upon the suffering
of a large number
of non-human animals.
I take it that you noticed last
week and the week before,
when the snow was falling long
Yale's campus, and the routes
were made clear for you to
get to classes, that the
possibility of you walking
across campus depended upon a
large number of people whose
lives are already difficult
getting up very early in
the morning and doing
back-breaking shoveling
work in the ice cold.
I trust that somebody has let
you in on the secret that the
clothes that you wear and from
which you take a certain
amount of pleasure are in a
great number of cases produced
as a result of something quite
close to the Omelas story,
namely child labor.
Indeed I take it that most
of you are aware that the
structure of the modern world
bears a rather shocking
similarity to the
Omelas story.
The possibility of flourishing
in the first world is in many
ways a consequence of an
inequitable structure with
regard to the third world.
Now, almost all of you gave an
answer that said this sort of
structure is at least
schematically morally
acceptable.
And the question is what
is going on there.
Le Guin in her story suggested
you as college students are at
exactly the age where the
salience of this may affect
you most profoundly.
So she writes --
after being exposed to these
sorts of facts -- she says
"often the young people go home
in tears or in a tearless
rage when they've seen the child
on whose suffering the
fate of their society
depends and face
this terrible paradox.
They may brood over it
for weeks or years.
But as time goes by," she says,
"they begin to realize
that even if the child could be
released it would not that
much good if its freedom, a
little vague pleasure of
warmth and food, no doubt,
but little more."
Now one of the interesting
things about literature in
contrast to philosophy is that
it leaves it to you to
interpret what's going on.
And the fundamental question,
I think, of the Omelas story
is whether this sentence, "They
begin to realize that
even if the child could be
released, it would not get
much good if its freedom, a
little vague pleasure of
warmth and food, no doubt, but
little more," is in fact
true--or whether it is the sort
of rationalization that
recognition of one's comfort
brings with it.
She goes on perhaps explaining,
perhaps protesting
too much, to say the following,
"It's too degraded
and imbeciled to know
any real joy.
It has been afraid for too long
ever to be free of fear.
Its habits are too uncouth for
it to respond to humane
treatment." Indeed think about
arguments about bringing
democracies to countries with
no tradition of democracy.
"After so long, it would
probably be wretched without
walls about it to protect it and
darkness for its eyes, its
own excrement to sit in.
Their tears at the bitter
justice dry when they begin to
perceive the terrible justice of
reality and to accept it."
Now, I don't have an answer to
which of the two readings that
I proposed is the right one to
make of the Le Guin case.
Is she contending there or
helping you to recognize there
that early feeling of rage at
the fact that your well-being
depends upon the suffering of
others is, in fact, and
immature response to an
inevitable structure of
inequity in the world?
Or is she suggesting that in
coming to think that way you
are letting go of your only
chance for moral behavior,
that it's at the moment when you
are profoundly exposed to
injustice, and it hits you in
the form of tears or rage that
you are in a position to bring
that into your life?
She suggests regardless that
living your life with your
eyes open to the fact that your
well-being depends upon
the suffering of others
is morally mandatory.
"It is their tears and anger,"
she continues, "the trying of
their generosity and the
acceptance of their
helplessness, which is perhaps
the true source of the
splendor of their lives.
They know that they, like the
child, are not free, that they
live in a world of mutual
interdependence.
"They know compassion.
It is because of their awareness
of suffering in the
world," she writes, "It is
because of that child that
they are so gentle with
their children.
They know that if the wretched
one were not there sniveling
in the dark," if we were not
provided with the resources
that let the first world thrive
as it does, "the other
one, the flute player would make
no joyful music." All of
the things that we benefit from,
the greatness up this
university, wouldn't be here.
"No joyful music as a young
writers line up for their
beauty of the race in the
sunlight on the first morning
of summer."
So I want to leave you with that
as one of the many things
which we can take from the
Omelas story and as an
introduction to what really goes
into making a claim like
the one Mill does.
And what we'll talk about next
class in the context of Kant
are some systematic critiques
which are offered of the
utilitarian framework from the
writings of Bernard Williams
and our alternate which is
offered in the writings of
Immanuel Kant.
So I'll see you on Tuesday.